so a 70 year old British man went in for
a bladder operation and came out with a
circumcised penis he ended up winning
20,000 pounds in a lawsuit that's it
20,000 pounds yeah also I feel like they
did him a favor although snip you gotta
get an anteater
again I just have makeup on my penis so
I don't know I don't have an I got I got
my smile I got two helmets out bro is it
I feel you have an auntie I'm jealous
yeah he does I was born in Korea I don't
know aegeon countries unless you're
super religious like Christian did
circumcisions generally Asians are well
that's something that's not the worst
thing like can you imagine if they went
and gave him a like gender reassignment
surgery and your dick got lost off then
I'm [ __ ] mad cuz that penis is my life
right but so you step a little bit a
little bit of foreskin you're alright
move on yeah so yeah but 20,000 pounds
homeboy should at least got a hundred K
out of that at least right here's my
thing with guys that have anteaters they
say it like because that's how you were
born with a hood for a reason it's more
sensitive loops the thing up it's
actually better but I don't know cuz I
was the way that you were doing this in
their hands was concerning and hilarious
like the way like wizards but you can
clean it more often I think that's a lie
yeah come on no it is scientifically
proven you clean yet the clean work as
you get bacteria oh you mean pull the
hood back like yes dude in that wish you
washing up maybe go don't have to do
that I don't either
turns out pressure washers work great
ready to go let's go let's put our let
me see yeah but see I think anteaters
Hollywood aft does our uncle how are you
guys gonna doc how did you say it would
you say what how you gonna dock what do
you mean you know what docking is no bro
bro really wait docking is where one
penis yes those in the other penises
foreskin and it talks like a space
shuttle
oh no that's not refueling it's doing
like planes you know but the medical
term docking pissing and then if you get
to docks you can actually go back and
forth like and you like it's you piss
into a hot dog in a corn dogs
Trebek so an anteater gets with a helmet
and they docked up like they're it's so
much remotely near Lane this guy thinks
I'm a big welcome to fighter the kid
Sanders on and this is where I do it
right
I'm loving this how much more fun is it
Bernie's gonna die any day now yeah
while Dawkins interesting I also like
here's the thing though you being on
circumcise such an advantage
God made you guys there's some evidence
for circumcised men are less likely to
attract infections or lower risk for
sexually transmitted but the thing is is
I'm a you know have a son is your son
circumcised hey it's a tough decision
ma'am I kid I didn't want to do it but
my girls super you know Catholic Mexican
they want to do it I had to leave the
hospital it's such a weird why in the
Bible Moses a sense bro I will cut he's
that word came from yes to show
subservience to God it's such a weird
look that up first it makes no sense in
over the Old Testament house so is that
what came of a religious belief to be
subservient to God and then now we
carried on that early place it came from
that's the only reason why it's with the
Jewish religious yeah it was actually a
Jewish interesting then it was adopting
the United States it's kind of a health
thing and all that but look at this
you're a special operations and penis
expert Brian now he knows God many have
been taught that an exodus God is
seeking to kill Moses than the response
Zipporah circumcised their son to avert
God's wrath this is supported by the
Midrash midre
which is Jewish and interpreting that
passage I'm gonna hold on but I guess
the exist pass also is a term bridegroom
of blood in many translations this
passion is provides many students of the
world that's it he did try to kill Moses
I guess hmm interesting well it makes
sense
guess guess we're doing it it's so weird
though there's no script or scriptural
basis for taking the life of father does
not circumcise a son punishment for
failing to be circumcised falls upon the
child not the father Genesis 17 for
moreover the Fela to be circumcised is
punishable by exclusion from the
Abrahamic covenant meaning you're not a
Jew anymore not death you know what dude
here's the prom I cap kids have another
son coming in November if it's up to me
I'm outnumbered dude I just my girl's
whole thing she's like you know you're
not you're circumcised so their penis
can be different in yours so didn't be
asking on these questions like you break
it down I'm pretty simple kids are
smartest [ __ ] man you just tell like
yeah yeah but by the time you're of that
age I don't think they're gonna be like
knowing what your penis look like it's
like that's like something you learn in
sex ed and probably in like sixth grade
or some [ __ ] I'd imagine sighs later so
you can do it later hurts more but you
can do it later but I will say this you
can do it later stuff you can do it at
70 or with an angel is saying yeah they
put him out but they did my kid might
because my dad was there I had to leave
the hospital is gonna kill somebody and
my dad said they gave like sugar cuz
babies they haven't had sugar they do it
early like that when it's two days old
they I'm sure he's like oh [ __ ] Leo yeah
cool right snip my keep you and cry I
feel like my dad's lying they didn't
give him by any aesthetic I don't they
might I know they get they like numb it
then they get the sugar and he goes oh
this is sugar that's like math for a kid
we're not imagine you couldn't put use a
lot of like you know anything that numb
the pain on that infant within reason by
use a local local anesthetic I imagine
but yeah I'm sure that hey dad to cut
off a lot a lot of skin we're we're in
the trespass don't truth here man hey
yeah good genes huh get it cut off a lot
of genes so the doctors like is like a
sheep what else we got
just watch over a second shut your
girl's hand said said it but it's crazy
when you're a parent you make those
decisions right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been do
[Laughter]